i wanted to ask a question ask a
question and then i'm going to go before
we go because it's i was obsessed with
your illuminati talk illuminati talk on
i don't believe that i saw that
you believe in illuminati i wanted to
bring it up i don't know why you don't
want to bring it up but i am so
obsessed with that conversation you guys
believe in the illuminati uh in theory
have you ever watched the documentary
fall of cabal no you should watch i i
don't know it's on bit shoot open up
your mind i don't believe in it no
there's no way you've been approached by
them you've been in this industry for a
while come on so you said everyone
you've asked says like yeah of course
i've never heard anyone what are you
doing you know listen i think that
there's one statement you made on that
other podcast that i kind of agreed on
you know you give the name there are
people in power that can get things done
right right but i don't think they go
around wearing illuminati like t-shirts
and i don't think they're an organized
group i think that there are little
pockets of organized like whether
they're in show business whether at at
some time it was like harvey weinstein
who was you know an illuminati for
creating a movie star illuminati i
thought you were talking about lou
minati i went to high school with them
that's another shirt we should create
anyway
the conspiracies of lou and his comments
do you believe that there's an organized
group no it's exactly what you said like
i do think that there are there's a
higher power that like makes decisions
but i don't think it's like they're
sacrificing people and they worship the
devil no but you have a publicist in the
other room that's going to make a
decision of what our audience is going
to be able to hear from you or not no
you shield your body
no but i'm just saying natalie is she
illuminati no so there's levels of she's
got that sports illustrated gig so maybe
she's the right person she should be
asking
no but to to add to the story i was
talking about how this girl was like
yeah she kind of wanted to get into the
whatever she's approached by the
illuminati yeah anyway i was approached
by someone yeah yeah by someone um and a
couple weeks later we were at somebody's
house for a party i don't want to say
the guy's name but he's really close to
michael jackson
and and i remember we were we were we
were sitting we were sitting in his room
and
this girl started talking about this man
she was approached by and he got really
worried and concerned and he started and
he was like please
please don't don't do anything with them
they ruined michael's life and he was
like really like adamant about it and he
was like really positive about that so
the answer to that is there is somebody
who is powerful in this town that was uh
pulling some strings to get this girl
whatever she wanted and he's probably a
very dangerous person but it's not part
of a uh uh you sound awfully defensive
about the illuminati because i don't
like that people i don't think that
people need to
again it's
back to the overthinking
no yeah but it's just like a conspiracy
like people just the idea of a handful
of people running the world
is that what you're saying yeah
basically yeah you don't think that
that's possible i think you think about
the rockefellers
yes yeah but so they run there are
people that run real estate in new york
yeah
they changed the doctrine of the medical
school it's all relatively because they
they created
uh pills of medicine that were
petroleum-based they ran all of the
oil and gas right they changed the
doctrine of medical schools the pharma
the pharmaceutical the absolutely but
you're saying that they're just super
powerful people that have a lot of money
not necessarily and a lot of power i
believe what's the difference between
that and what we're doing because what
you're the the they may occasionally
come together and
wear goat skull the same person that
makes your girl the girl that you know
famous the same group that makes your
the person that you know famous is not
the same person that uh kind of uh
created a uh turn in the pharmaceutical
companies is not the s from the same
group of persons oh totally yeah i i
think that there are like different
there's lobbying groups the optometrist
made it a law because this is along the
same lines that that if you wanted to
get your eyes exact get glasses you have
to get your eyes examined first so
the point is that that's a law you can't
get glasses without having your eyes
examined first and that's a group of
folks that got together you
why would you if you didn't go to
optometrist how would you know what your
prescription is well maybe you want a
new pair of glasses you'd have to get
another exam no you don't but you know
that you know like the crazy conspiracy
of he's kind of right i can't get a new
pair of contacts without getting an eye
exam
so unless losing the loan so there is
illuminati
[Music]
you